[Musique]
bonjour l'actualité européenne nous
allons tenter de vous la faire vivre
malgré de confinement imposé par le
committee 9 votre émission europe hebdo
sada chaque semaine nous allons vous
proposer des interviews de personnalités
politiques comme opel afin de voir
notamment quelles sont les réponses
apportées dans les pays membres de
l'union pour faire face à cette crise
sanitaire inédite et les premières la
montée eux deux
puisque du parlement européen à
bruxelles c'est vous rendra soit bonjour
bonjour madame vous êtes tellement
efficace un conservateur le ppe
nous parlerons avec sont évidemment de
la stratégie de l'allemagne et d'angela
merkel mais avant nous avons parlé
d'europe
vous étiez dans l'hémicycle européen en
séance plénière jeudi matin si c'est
important pour vous d'être
l'élément votre mandat européen est en
crise
oui c'est important pour le parlement
européen ouvre citoyens dans ce moment
difficile que non seulement nous voulons
faire ensemble
tout ce qui est possible pour aider à la
population dans les états mort mais
aussi que nous sommes prêts à exercer le
contrôle ce qui concerne les actions de
la pro mission européenne est qu'une
somme n'a pour faire face à cette crise
ensemble quelques
sanitaires mises en place par le
parlement européen jeudi matin le vote à
distance était possible vous étaient peu
nombreux d'ailleurs dans l'hémicycle
c'est vrai qu'il ya quarante cinq scènes
en ce moment et c'est vrai que le
parlement est inscrite car les
assistants il est conseillé travail à la
maison et donc il ya un dispositif qui
est là la vie d'emma ont nettoyé de tous
des services pour nettoyer tout c'est
ainsi que les organiser
parler du fond donc avez vous voté ce
jeudi matin dernier des fonds
supplémentaires pour soutenir l'économie
européenne absolument nous avons
absolument ensemble avec une majorité
écrasante de 687 et aucune abstention
voté pour que les états membres puissent
profiter
la ned à disney de environ 35 milliards
d'euros pour investir dans le système
sanitaire est est ce que vous êtes pour
mettre les normes sont de sortie
par l'un de 400 en tout 400 800
milliards d'euros à disposition des
états membres comme souhaité par
certains états comme la france l'italie
ou l'espagne
est ce que vous êtes pour cela mais
c'est prématuré selon vous alors je
pense la chose qu'il faut faire
maintenant c'est de sauver les vies dans
des hôpitaux de faire en sorte que ceux
qui sont encore sans inflexion
dangereuse reste à la maison et se
protègent là
il faut que nous nous qui on a vu dans
cette crise il faut d'abord penser aux
hommes ou femmes mais surtout que ces
hommes et ces femmes ont besoin de
survivre il faut donc aussi penser à
l'économie et comment la relancer il
commet la maintenir
tant que les biens et les services
soient pas arrêté à nos frontières il
est à prévoir
d'accord on entendait notamment pour se
protéger il faut des parce qu'il manque
de solidarité de coopération de
concertation en europe et weill et
parfois criant je voudrais revenir avec
vous sur ces centaines de milliers de
masques destinés à l'italie confisqué
volée on peut même dire à la république
tchèque commençait de succès cinq mille
euros c'est pas là un aveu terry de
d'échec absolument ça ne peut pas du
tout être la réalité dans l'union
européenne
de tout ça et je dois vous dire que
malheureusement tous les états membres
vous même en allemagne il ya des bases
qui ont été confisqués voler ou arrêtés
aux quelques maisons qui étaient là et
apparemment il y avait des gens avec
coffre fort qu'ils voulaient acheter
directement sans délai
en tout état de cause c'est pas facile
si les états commencent à bloquer les
produits de l'autre
t difficile pour les ministres en charge
de voir que des biens qui sont sur leur
terrain par le pays a besoin de ces
produits et là on voit les lances à eau
la coopération entre les états notamment
entre l'allemagne et la france
on peut voir un hélicoptère de secours
allemand prendre en charge depuis
mulhouse des malades en scène pour les
emmener dans les hôpitaux
outre-rhin en de la schwab c'est aussi
ça le rock
c'est vrai que dans ma circonscription
[Musique]
et pour cette raison on a pris un
certain nombre de français dans des
hôpitaux universitaires
c'est bien clairement un signe fort de
l'autre côté ça va pas être suffisant
pas la solution on l'entend mais est ce
que ça veut dire que l'allemagne est
aussi en mesure de supporter
d'accueillir des malades venus de
l'europe de l'italie de la france parce
qu'il ya un plus grand nombre de lits en
réanimation ou en allemagne
li 6 de soins intensifs ont des raisons
des années 60 il expliqué mais il n'est
pas aussi facile de transporter des
patients de la france non seulement
limité pour des hélicoptères mais il ya
aussi des barrières devant et d'autres
qui font voeu de l'allemagne
et des autres et on le sait on l'entend
et avant d'aborder un plan détaille la
stratégie allemande face au co g19 je
vous propose d'écouter en gala merkel la
chancellière allemande exprimé très
solennellement
c'était le 18 mars dernier c'est sérieux
rené le aussi au sérieux depuis la
réunification allemande
noah depuis la seconde guerre mondiale
il n'y a pas eu de défis pour notre pays
qui dépendent autant de notre solidarité
comme moi
des mots forts on l'entend lâche pas
bête la part du gouvernement une par une
prise de conscience très tôt de la
gravité de la situation d'un parent
langue et la merkel
je pense chaque pays savaient qu'il y a
l'arrivée de ce virus mais en politique
il faut prendre des mesures aussi dures
seulement si le moment la caso comprend
la gravité de la situation et à ce
moment là la merkel avec une stratégie
allemand de très différente de celle en
france comment se fait-il qu'ils aient
peu de morts on annuel par rapport à la
france il ya notamment dit
de dépistage en allemagne c'est une
stratégie que vous validez h preuve je
dois vous dire que j'étais un peu
surpris que les applications veux qu'on
prenne les mesures au moment nécessaire
paris bordeaux
finalement heureusement
et attendant la généralisation du
dépistage notamment en france où
commence à suivre l'allemagne 8
donc c'est une bonne chose qu'il y ait
un peu plus de cohérence entre les
différentes décisions sanitaire
absorption et ont pu ou long terme à la
faim la crise des deux côtés les mêmes
du sud on y est arrivé
chose les fêtes espérons que ces
responsables s'explique apparemment
commencé et je dis et éviter de perdre
d'autres villes écoutez nous serons à
aller vous l'a remercié le pape d'avoir
répondu à mes questions de closets
sportez vous bien et a très vite je
l'espère au sein même du parlement
européen fiable merci beaucoup
robin
[Musique]